so we're looking at particularly if you
want to make a heading for this call it
multimedia production software we're
particularly focused on that because
there's a whole other family of software
that has to do with just viewing
multimedia okay so we want to look at
the production creation construction
editing and processing type alright
so whatever the walkthrough is for
primary categories of software for doing
this okay and we're going to do a
cost-benefit analysis for each one so
that's why we're gonna have a look at
what each one is and then we're going to
go through advantages of disadvantages
okay
and the typical users over on the right
it's more for you so that when we come
back to this later you'll be like wait
what is this and then you can think of
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
start from the most basic the most basic
and I said that was Microsoft Word now
that's just one example I don't call
these multi-purpose multi-purpose
applications
and the examples we're gonna have will
have examples for each one so DUI
multiplayer what does that mean okay
well first one Microsoft Word I'm also
going to lump in excel here okay and
you're free to disagree with that these
definitions these categories that are
going to go through they're kind of
elastic they're not like very set in
stone but you sort of get a general idea
so I said I was gonna start with the
simplest what are some advantages and
disadvantages of say using a program
like word to create some multimedia hmm
what advantages do you think jump out to
you yeah
good yes excellent so um we would say
the good thing that's is its widespread
okay so I'm gonna have pluses and
minuses here now by the way just it
being widespread that has its own
advantages and disadvantages right but I
guess what we would say is you know it's
great you saying you want to create
something and maybe work alongside other
people on it because you know they all
have it too
probably okay the fact that it's
widespread also leads to another one on
a scale of 1 to 10 how would you rate
the difficulty of using Microsoft Word 1
1 to 10 you know maybe 2 or 3 depending
what you're trying to do with it so I
suppose what we would say is I'm ease of
use ease of use and in fact really
another way of saying the same thing is
maybe I should pose this question how
much formal training did you go through
in order to start using Microsoft Word
the first time you did it right unless
anyway uh you don't need to write so I
minimum will actually no training really
is required if you want to create some
multimedia like you want to make a basic
little flyer or something or a birthday
invite or something you can just jump in
very very simple okay now I probably
want to add one more thing which is how
much does much of what cost
well I mean to you guys - yeah yes
suppose you buy office together my
people don't usually buy just one of
them and you guys have it free right cuz
it's just bundle it in with you but it's
it's quite low cost on the scale of
things okay so I'm gonna say low cost
now before I get to the disadvantages
just because I'm running out of screen
real estate what are some typical uses
of word I'd probably say mostly we use
it for personal use right personal
communications I suppose for you guys
school projects so the thing that he
shared common is that they're really
quite simple but they're not overly
complicated okay and it's okay if they
don't look super flashy it just gets the
job done right now still thinking about
this category can we think about
something the disadvantages
well what disadvantages or frustrations
or difficulties if you guys come up with
using word
let me see if you guys have this is ever
happened to you before I mean trying to
design something like say flyer or maybe
a magazine or a booklet or something
that you want to look too nice right
and then you paste some text in and the
formatting goes all weird on you right
like different parts of the paragraph or
in different colors of different fonts
or different spacing or it all looks
really nice it's all good and then you
email it to yourself you open it up at
school and it's like is this the same
document look completely different or
you send it to someone else and they
might have the same version of word or
slightly different one and still you've
got this problem of inconsistency okay
what's going on I'll call this lack of
control by which I mean and when we talk
about the different kinds of things that
you can customize in Word right you can
only adjust certain things you don't
have control over others I'm going to
give you some examples of things that
you can control later on and we go to
the next category that you can't control
and work but suffice to say that you
can't make everything look exactly as
you wanted to on little pen frustration
and minors in word you can't adjust the
angle of text did you know that maybe
maybe you never need to adjust the angle
of text okay you can either get it
straight across the page or up or down
that's it I kind of have it like off at
an angle or you can't have it i curves
around unless you use weed WordArt which
has its own problems okay so that's just
one little theme right so lack of
control okay in addition I probably say
my quality
and when you when you make that birthday
invitation for that reportin that kind
of thing and you're compared to say you
know if you were producing a magazine
you compare to a real magazine the until
the difference you can look at me like
oh okay tacky right where's the real
stuff you know they don't use word for
real magazines for some of the reasons
that we've just mentioned okay alright
so there are some advantages
disadvantages let's move on to the next
category so that was multi-purpose
applications and the next one is what we
call what the Ring packages and in your
examples you gave me a couple probably
ones like say Photoshop I think we
mentioned Crimea as well these are good
examples of software but you can see is
definitely a step up on the things that
we were looking at before how would you
distinguish what kind of different
qualities advantages disadvantages do
you think there are between applications
like this and the ones we were looking
at there for you can always tell from
the name
these are multi-purpose applications how
are these different by contrast
they're sort of well they're not so
multi-purpose right so example I in
Microsoft Word you can pretty much put
every kind of multimedia type you can
even stick a video in if you really
desperately want it right don't know how
to look on the page when you print it
out but anyway whereas when you're going
to these kinds of things right they're
far more specific aren't they and with
that specificity you get greater control
we've been talking about I between our
magazines right one of the you guys
probably aren't that familiar that Adobe
also releases is called InDesign I had
to use it because I was creating able
clip for something at uni one time and
when I opened it up I realized I could
control what's called waiting on fonts
do you remember we were looking at fonts
before waiting what's waiting about it's
about you know sort of like this imagine
you can take any font you like right and
you can have a complete really fine
control over how thick every letter is
and how far apart they're all the
letters are and so on and so on right so
that kind of control allows you to you
know make your multimedia law more
professional right however you know what
kind of disadvantage when you open up
Photoshop how long does it take on
average and your laptop's open up you
know I think if you're lucky maybe 60
seconds if you're lucky if you're
running Eric anything else at the same
time you might be going to you know two
minutes three minutes maybe depending on
what you're doing right so how would you
describe that as a disadvantage
how would you articulate that long
loading times we're not necessarily long
loading times long loading times if your
processes are not very powerful right so
I guess what we would say here is
processing needs
okay it's needs a powerful processor
needs a fair bit of RAM okay in the same
way I wonder if you remember the first
time you opened up premier okay and I
think probably most of you dabble with a
little bit just try and think back well
even if you want to do it now when you
can premier you open it up and then when
you just go to new fire hope right I
think what happens when you got a word
you say new file and it's like there's a
there's a page Neela okay I don't do
with this awesome click here and I'll
start typing right but when you're in
premier and you say new file it do you
remember it possible is for this dialog
and it's like what would you like to
what kind of thing would you like and
there are all these different options
for like pal and NTSC and this kind of
resolution in this frame rate and you
think about you're like okay so he's my
point
um no trainings are quiet for these
kinds of applications that designed just
so you can jump in and work it out as
you go okay but if you do that with
premier you're handsome you're in for
some infrared it's not gonna be a fun
time okay so I guess what I'd take here
is there's minimal or you know there is
some training required you guys are
pretty bright so you probably could just
dive in with no help okay
but there's going to be for most of us
some actually you know like help files
or someone who knows how to use the
program that'll be needed oh yeah no
actually I totally meant it's me a
negative sorry thank you yes so so this
is a this is a drawback right sorry for
them for something okay good
in the same way it's gonna be higher
costs right so you go up to Toby's
website right and you'll get thousands
of dollars for the basic I'm Suites
right as opposed to a few hundred
dollars for the other stuff okay what
one of the typical uses of stuff over
here and by the way I didn't take
typical because I know you don't have to
do it this way you could do if you
wanted to you could do you know your
school projects in these kinds of
applications or you could do your
personal communications in these but
generally speaking it's not
as we move up to these I think we're
looking at semi-professional products
often things that are subject to public
presentation right so you know if you're
getting a fly up and you know the
council has got to release a flyer
they're gonna make it one then we're
gonna wint one to make it look more
professional then can just be put out
with Microsoft Word and it's in Comic
Sans and you're like oh wait if we're to
put out a good image to the council
right so things are heady and the public
people will generally want to use these
more expensive more sophisticated kinds
of software okay all right
mmm the third kind of category is what
we call scripting software
and I think when we went around we
didn't really I don't think anyone
really mention any examples and
admittedly because most of us don't
really have to worry about this kind the
most closest example for you guys is
probably something like say Dreamweaver
okay I don't mean to be biased I'm just
picking out a lot of Adobe stuff because
I know you guys have heard of it and
you've got in front of you so you can
actually have a look at it
Dreamweaver and other things called
integrated development environments
Yossarian integrated development
environments people in sta will use
these a bit more what's the idea here
your scripting something the whole
concept is that when you are say in
Google Sites you can muck around you can
put pictures in and all that kind of
thing
but behind all of the things that you're
editing there's a script a language a
code that's actually telling your
multimedia what it's going to look like
right so scripting software allows you
direct control over that okay
so what does that give you it gives you
higher quality and flexibility
when I say flexibility I mean things
like what we were talking about your
group project earlier in the year and
you're using Google Sites Google Sites
kind of sits somewhere in between here
these first two categories right and one
of the things that it gives you is
templates and lots of pre-designed
things you can work with but when you're
like oh I want my header to look like
this or I want to have these kinds of
things in my footer or I want to adjust
the background in this way often you
guys said to me oh my hands are tied I
can't do it it's not flexible enough
okay
when you can script and muck around with
the actual code that's behind there you
get more and more control so you can do
more and more different kinds of things
okay in addition to that one of the
great things you can build in with
scripting software is interactivity
usually if you want something to be able
to if you want to use it to be able to
interact with something you can't really
do it with those methods above there
just for consumption but you would use
scripting software to say make and now
I'm looking at typical users here to
make websites right that's where we see
the most because these are interactive
things right web sites you might say or
web services so you know you're not
gonna make a Facebook or a Twitter with
any of the tools up here okay you're
gonna have to dig into something a
little deeper okay now those are some
advantages what are some disadvantages
there as you may want to jump in okay
good I cost much more expensive and not
just by the way I'm glad you mentioned
cost not just the cost of the
application itself but also if you are a
company and you want to start to delve
into this kind of level of
professionalism you're not just gonna
have to buy expensive software you're
probably gonna have to get dedicated
staff people who really know their stuff
people who actually have prior
experience to this know how it works as
opposed to our you and me we can just
sort dive in and work it out okay
that's gonna take forever you sort of
need specialized people with actual
experience with the software okay let me
give you one more disadvantage just as
before I said one of the great things
about Microsoft Word right is you can
pretty much create a um a presentable
multimedia theme in a matter of minutes
right you grab some pictures put it in
format okay
when you're scripting something you
wouldn't get anywhere in a matter of
minutes in a matter of minutes you'll be
like hooray I've got a web page that's
blank you know because you're just
starting to get the code right okay so
therefore we're trying to talk about
your speed right such much slower
development
okay now the last one and we talked that
scripting software so software like this
like say Dreamweaver it won't make you
by hand code out do all the way or do
that kind of thing it'll sort of give
you a bit of a a bit of a guide and
assist you with some things but if you
want to go one step down further beyond
that you're gonna write all the code
yourself
and so the lasts highest kind of
multimedia production software is
already called a programming language
right so there are heaps of examples
like that say C++ is a name you might
have heard before you don't even know
what it is but just that it is a
programming language Java JavaScript -
the list goes on you don't need to know
too much about them just that they are
different languages okay
now also I've alluded to this before
these are kinds of ones that are quite
common right people out there will learn
them and they're sort of standards but
they're also what I call proprietary
languages you don't know what
proprietary means hmm I'd say important
word when it comes to take do I have it
going yeah yeah that's the idea so
here's the thing I just took it out if I
want to plug in a USB right into a USB
memory drive into my computer I know
that this is a standard lots of people
use it's very comment and I can just
plug in right but if I want to plug in
say an iPhone right I know that a
standard plug isn't enough I need a
special one a proprietary one one that
was built by the company that made the
phone okay and there will know if it is
so what I mean about this in terms of
programming languages is sometimes I'm
this is an example I'd like you to look
up in a bit later sometimes companies
will write their own specific
programming languages for a very
specific purpose I'll get to this one in
a second
before we do that let's start thinking
about some examples and typical uses
okay so the advantages disadvantages are
sort of all the previous things we've
said already but in the extreme right so
they're the highest quality you've got
the highest level of control
yeah in the same way when you go here
you're not just gonna need like one or
two extra people to help you with this
you might like have a whole department
for and they'll call it engineering so
special expertise and in fact because
the art of programming right is such a
tough art to so many sometimes you don't
just need special expertise that gets
this sometimes the people who understand
is are so different and think in such a
different way to the other people that
design people that you even need to
employ people who are in between who
understand both of these guys to sort of
mediate between them so companies get
huge if they're trying to do something
like this okay so where do we see these
where they get used kinds of multimedia
we think you most of you probably have
it in your pocket yeah yeah far and away
the biggest kind of multimedia that'll
use specialized programming languages
but not just that you know talk about
films it used to be that you know
animated films or films with special
effects used to be their own category
but now they're just everywhere you know
you can't even watch a normal TV series
like say um like Grey's Anatomy without
there are green screens in all these
different shots and different visual
effects that have to be applied so these
kinds of things get brought in okay now
I talked about this example what is this
we can go and look this up later this is
a special this is the name of the
language that was built by I believe is
when a digital well they famous for
they're about to get real famous again
one of the rings okay now what they had
in Lord of the Rings I don't know if you
know you guys are probably like two
years old
anyway uh they are one of the first big
movies which had lots and lots of people
in battle scenes right so there's like
fifty thousand orcs and fifty thousand
elves and all that kind of thing right
now we were looking before at cel
animation and all that and we said oh
it's great now we can do 3d animations
and that's much better guess what when
you're fifty thousand people like you
know let's say a tiller of the Hun
that's why you know it's named after him
even that with 3d model he's still a
challenge okay so a language was created
to create the battle scenes does that
make sense
language prepared just for that to
govern the individual models in their
behavior and all that kind of thing so
look realistic we talked about in
Monsters Inc we talked about one of the
main characters and then what his name
was Sully and the weird thing about it
was he was covered in hair in fur right
and that hair that fur guess what they
wrote a proprietary programming language
to manage all the physics behind what is
fur like when there was you know snow
getting caught in his fur that's hard
you know who works that out it's not
manually done a programming language was
designed for him when the wind blows and
when he jumps up and down and so on and
so forth so there you go
there's four different kinds of
categories now what I want you to do is
I want you to go back through the lists
of multimedia production software that
you came up with and I want you to try
and fit it into one of these four and
perhaps if you end up with some that are
a bit bare be like oh I have nothing in
here okay we're gonna go and see if you
can find some ok off you go